what was the post-war style play is the
south today still marked by the Civil
War and what took place after the Civil
War I'm going to get that down south you
know for some period of time there's a
self different from the North still your
bid how's it different other than being
hotter we're having fire ants up their
regular ants you know I got stung by
them I heard like hell how's it sound
different yeah there's still kind of be
at least I feel is still kind of um some
mixed feelings about everything that
happened between the Union and the south
okay so that's actually a good way to
put it mixed feelings about the American
Civil War was a mighty ACW and what he
happened immediately after the war there
was like another period that didn't
affect the north so much it was called
reconstruction because the South was
basically torn up Sherman had marched
across the entire areas and just risked
everything to shred those part of the
war strategy it was also about changing
society so you're right there even today
there's still some mixed feelings about
that in the 1920s goes a bit much
stronger mixed feelings your book talks
about a sort of tragic civil religion
that's all you know is very much focused
on the region and you know saw the south
is this is beaten down but you know
ultimately morally victoria's power
that's part of this we didn't you didn't
have other parts of the united states
that had that kind of chip on their
shoulder about that because they hadn't
been conquered in fact you know when
they talk in old stories about the War
of Northern Aggression that's the way a
lot of people in
actually did see the Civil War this
other cells is kind of a Concord but
still defiant people we're talking about
how they panned out with religion what
also could you say about this out yeah
very good more rural there's not as many
big cities Atlanta's a huge city but you
get outside of Atlanta and you get to
some of the other cities when I lived
out in fayetteville north carolina i was
very surprised to realize that a big
city was you know 300,000 people at
charlotte whereas i'm used to big cities
several million people like chicago
milwaukee you know even indianapolis as
a million people if you count the
suburbs so you know compare that to up
here you guys having bigger cities the
South looks very rural another thing you
might say is less developed particularly
at the time that we're looking at in
terms of infrastructure here's something
that sort of a little bit of trivia that
you may not have realized you know one
of the little stereo types of
southerners is that they're they're not
really hard-working that lesson that
they tend to be you know not on time
they're going to be able to laksa days
ago about stuff one of the reasons why
that was you know a stereotype that
could arise as many of the people in the
south until the turn of this last
century actually had parasites that were
causing them you know to actually feel
the larger much of the time you didn't
wear shoes there are worms that will
actually grow up into your body from the
soil and it took a while to stamp that
sort of thing out it actually holds for
a lot of cases worldwide where
people are suffering some sort of
parasite infestation what else would you
say about this out those of you who
traveled in it or have some impressions
so infrastructure is not as developed a
prepared what else yeah yeah there's
there's a sense of friendliness but also
if you go to the wrong places people
don't want to have too much to do it
right they see more deep you even
religion in general okay we're going to
put friendliness within limits okay so
that's something we can say about today
right religion is a more important
factor in a lot of people's lives
southern southerners on the whole that
you would say I'm more religious than
people in the north or about glass and
that that's you know there's some basis
for that today part of the period that
we're looking at that actually wasn't
the case when have something though so
we'll tell that story in or anything
else that you would put up here yeah why
you so what I obviously what is kind of
a weird it's like big terrorism asst
it's weird I notice like that you know
like people would kind of like secretly
like you know religiously know they do
through different like religions that
you know especially there's no Spanish
see what hispanics yeah legs are
primarily to be lights and you know
that was like a connection and legally
they were they really try and get that
much so let's move that up you know
north a little bit into the deep south
this Florida's actually further south in
the deep south he had we can talk in
terms of segregation in segregation
means people are kept apart on the basis
of something what was the the major
segregating factor was in class it was
engendered it was white himself race ya
along with that would often go
segregation in terms of religion if
you're talking about like southern
Florida their religion would be a thing
because it's white so probably any
Protestants for the most part or Jewish
right and then what would the Hispanics
probably be Catholic yeah maybe some
some sound too great i'm coming from
Cuba so you know sometimes racial
segregation will be sort of
automatically to religious segregation
as well or the two can reinforce each
other there were a lot of churches in
the South that were in fact segregate
director much of the South's history so
what talks about regionalism these are
all aspects of southern regionalism
regionalism means that you think that
your region really counts as part of
your identity in a way that's different
than many other people I mean you know
New Yorkers are often proud of being
from New York especially people from the
city as opposed to upstate I mean a lot
of upstanders don't worship or city
there's there's some rivalries back and
forth but it's not quite the same as the
south is it there's a lot of other
places too where people are like yeah
I'm from someone's phone it doesn't
matter I don't care a lot of people feel
that least you know at this time that
we're looking at that being from the
South makes them fundamentally different
so we won't look at some of the ways in
which this is the case your book to act
in terms of subculture and
it also defines what they mean by the
cell so they said geographically the
south is coextensive with the 11 states
that seceded to form the Confederacy
large part over the continuing existence
of slavery one traditional appointed
demarcation was the mason-dixon line
cultural geographers have argued that
old route 40 could work which is you
know a lot of Indiana would actually be
considered south by that measure and
then make sense actually because Indiana
was settled by people moving up from the
south from Kentucky into most of Indiana
southern Illinois is actually culturally
very southern when I went down there
they actually called me a Yankee I was
very surprised being from Wisconsin one
stayed up people would actually call you
a Yankee and there were times that I
would go into in southern Illinois where
they would not actually like take money
out of your hand here to put it on the
counter and they wouldn't talk to you if
your home further north because there
was an animosity really kind of strange
that's getting very well you know you're
in the back highways now being southern
like it like it points out there's a
there's an ethnic background to that the
primary ethnicity for white Southerners
is coming from Great Britain various
parts of great plate we've talked about
this the scots-irish before Scott's as
well moved in there a lot of English
moved in there not a lot of other
ethnicities you didn't find he like in
Pennsylvania where a lot of German were
doing there because it was a haven for
tolerance the French weren't there and
afterwards after this is the American
Civil War there was a lot of sentiment
against immigration coming into the
south few attempts that were made were
generally rebuffed so now the other
major ethnic background for southerners
would be what two whites from primarily
England Scotland Northern Ireland what
was the other one determine
is pretty much the whole history of the
South African America right slavery was
was for the most part of southern
institution and by the time the American
Civil War it's an exclusively of
something institution so you've got a
massive white population ambassador
african-american population what's
missing there who else was there and
didn't get to hang around very much
better probably should mention a lot of
Native Americans and the South were
basically deported or absorbed by these
other two ethnicities so they don't play
a huge role in their religious landscape
so your book talks about about racism
quite a bit and we've talked about this
another chapter so I'm going to skip
over this somewhat except for focusing
on one tension that's their talks about
until the transformation brought about
by the civil rights movement in this
1960s free blacks of the South lived
under serious disabilities whether
sanctioned by law or simply social
custom economic leverage and the
ever-present threat of violent violence
so segregation mad that one entire race
of people was kept in a subordinate
position at the same time everyone is
living next to everybody else like your
book says weights and blacks have always
lived in close social contact not as
equals but often as intimate so this
leads to a real strong tension running
through Southern literature so the
religion so when we finally get to
religion late so since the early 19th
century black and white southerners have
been more deeply invisibly committed to
religion especially several varieties of
evangelical Protestantism than residents
of any other extended part of the nation
so this notion that the south is more
religious there's a basis for that it
wasn't originally like that remember
that term that we used before the
Church remember what that meant people
that just weren't part of any sort of
religious community large parts of the
south until the missionary work was done
there were unchurched part because the
dominant church in the south when these
were American colonies was the Anglican
Church they didn't do an awful lot of
mission work they were not very
transportable the ones who did were you
know the Baptist the Methodists to a
lesser extent the Presbyterians and
they're the ones who attended to catch
on it would be so I think it says
nothing outside of the evangelical
spectrum stood much of a chance for
widespread popular acceptance in the
south when you think of Christianity and
you think of the South you should think
of evangelicals for the most part
remember when I showed you that man
about who who dominates each county at
the beginning of the semester there's a
gigantic red area that was basically
coterminous with the old south with the
Baptist the Southern Baptist were the
largest group there's a reason for them
evangelicals are the ones who sort of
came out on top demographically not
necessarily in terms of the elite here's
where the Presbyterians and your fiscal
peleas so you put your book talks about
the Church of England and it also talks
about the Presbyterian Baptists and
looks at how they they differed in their
mission work from each other I'm going
to skip over that a bit because I want
to get to some of the other points that
they're making and I'm going to skip
over the the you know what he had in
their view of the Civil War all the
other than to say that it split churches
apart the method is hacking I'll split
into the northern Methodists or southern
Methodists and got back together
Presbyterians split northern
together the Baptist split and never did
get back together so the northern
Baptists and the Southern Baptists
remain separate denominations your book
talks about the spirituality of the
church this notion that the church is
really not about social engagement it's
about the individual and the individuals
need for for redemption for you know
personal change not so much the
community but the individual that's the
focus that the evangelical churches took
in the south so they says the dominant
cultural consensus favor the moral
reform of the individual preferably
through a religious conversion rather
than through religiously sanctioned
social engineering so you could say you
know well we've got a problem why don't
we change it let's change the side it's
a no no you have to focus on person
personal responsibility the person has
to decide to change they have to accept
you know religion it to their life and
make it part of their life or they're
not going to change so a lot of you've
angelical had a very strict personal
code of moral behavior which forbade
things like smoking alcoholic beverages
gambling theater sometimes movie-going
among Pentecostals wearing neckties and
using cosmetics so you've got a real
strong tension there because you think
about these things as being sort of
typically rural or soldering and at the
same time there's all these you know
people who don't fit in that way in the
Sun as well so there's a stronger
divided between the realm this is this
might be able you say this others are
more religious there's a stronger
divided between the realm of the
religious and the realm of the profane
if you're going to be in the profane
just be in gamble drink and do whatever
you're going to go but then if you're
going to be in the religious it's
understood as having me being fairly
strict I'm going to skip over the
discussion about about african-american
worship is
well because we're going to come back to
that later on one thing will will will
talk about before we be on this chapter
your book also has a lot of discussion
about other parts of the south and when
you get to the really rural parts of the
south religion is a bit different in its
emphasis here we're talking about me not
in the mountains like the Ozarks the
Appalachians and then it tends to be
focused more on independent
individualistic and highly expressive
variations of Baptist and wholly
Pentecostal themes so you have Baptist
churches that are not well represented
in other places like primitive Baptists
or old regular baptist that you'll find
another in these sort of places there's
a number of different folk religious
things that are tied in with the
cultures that things like Imelda
shape-note singing preaching style
that's more like a chant or wine an
ordinary spoken district discourse and
this is where we find the things like
snake handler I got very in a rare
minority type of thing not to be taken
as a characterization of Pentecostals in
general but there are our Pentecostal
churches that take off from the notion
that if you're saved you'll be able to
handle serpents and be able to drink
poisons not be affected one so the last
thing that your book actually talks
about here is the new notes up so that's
a good place to end and to think about
has a solid fundamentally change is
there really a new south in existence or
do a lot of the currents that we're
seeing here still carry through the end
the contemporary self